well the golden knights are busy making
sure some local family holidays are just
a little bit brighter
eight sports now kevin martin joining us
now in the newsroom with more on that
kevin
well hey denise with the nhl appearing
to be closing in on a start date for the
2021 season
you can bet teams are starting to ramp
up workouts in preparation for
training camp but several members of the
golden knights took time off the ice
today to give back to the las vegas
community
head coach pete devorah and goaltender
marc-andre fleury helped load bikes
outside of city national arena
which were delivered to help of southern
nevada campus
just a small gesture to help make
someone's holidays a little brighter
this year
such a tough time in this country and in
southern nevada and
you know it's an opportunity for us to
to
brighten some days of some families that
haven't had it easy uh
here lately i don't know it's not much
weight but i guess the team
tries hard you know to help people in
the community community and kids and
you know i'm just happy i could give a
hand there max patch ready nick holden
and zach whitecloud also made a special
check presentation on behalf of the
golden knights at the help of southern
nevada campus